(upbeat dance music)
- Oh, it's a nice place.
- Yeah, crazy how empty it is
for a Tuesday afternoon, though.
- What can I get you gentlemen?
- We will have two beers.
- Oh, no, no, no.
We only serve wine here.
- What am I, at my parents'?
I've never had wine before.
(gasps)
(easy rock music)
- I have tasted the forbidden fruit.
- With some sort of
child sacrifice for this.
- What year was this bottled?
I won't drink anything younger than 1800.
- I want seven pounds of a cheese platter.
- You can really taste
the notes of chocolate.
- I'm picking up hint of rocky road.
- Do you think maybe
it's because we visited
an ice cream parlor beforehand?
- Look at me, I'm a wine-nocerous.
Get it?
- This wine has a great set of legs,
like our model friend Heidi Klum.
(gargles)
That's good.
Ooh, what a fantastic
sauvignon blanc we're having.
- I love savi-nom-nom.
(laughs)
- I am so funny when I drink wine.
I should be on David Letterman.
- You're funnier than my court jester.
- Look at us just drinking
some gossip juice.
- Loose lips sink ships, and
I'm the captain of the Titanic.
- Did I tell you my son
Preston got suspended
from Academy again for
saying the word "sexy"
too much in class?
- Did you hear that
Brenda's husband got kicked
out of the country club because
he only tipped the caddy $50.
- Again?
- Again.
- Uh oh!
Looks like I'm about to
send an e-mail to my ex.
- What did he say?
- What do you mean you
want to meet tonight?
Look at me, I'm crying like a poor person.
- Does anyone have a hundred
dollar bill to blow my nose?
- I am not an alcoholic if it's wine.
Wine is good for you.
- We're never going to die.
(laughs)
(puking)
You're all right,
you're all right, buddy.
- Hold my hair back.
(puking)
(upbeat dance music)